vladimir putin has justified his
invasion of ukraine by claiming that
russian forces are conducting a special
operation to denazify the country
this ignores the fact that ukraine's
leader vladimir zelinski is himself
jewish
but in an interview on italian
television russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov dismissed zielenski's
faith because he suggested
many
[Music]
this has outraged israel the russian
ambassador was hauled into the israeli
foreign ministry today and the
government has been quick to publicly
criticize moscow
the remarks are an unforgivable scandal
hitler was not from jewish descendants
and the jews didn't kill themselves
during the holocaust we make every
effort to keep good relations with
russia but there's a limit and this
limit has been crossed this time
israel's holocaust memorial yad vashem
has called lavrov's words dangerous and
delusional
he's propagating
basically the inversion of the holocaust
the victims are deemed to be the
perpetrators this is
abhorrent this is despicable it is
contrary to historical truth
israel is one of the few countries in
the world to retain relatively warm
relations with moscow instead of arming
ukraine they've tried to balance their
own interests and play peacemaker
natalie bennett has been treading a
delicate and not wholly popular line
here in israel
the israelis need
a certain level of russian cooperation
on some matters for example bombing
iranian targets over the border in syria
but there have been newspaper editorials
here suggesting that the government
might find themselves on the wrong side
of history when it comes to ukraine
and after what sergey lavrov has had to
say
you can expect that domestic pressure
will increase here for israel to back
ukraine in the conflict lavrov's words
could therefore be a huge diplomatic
owned goal israel has demanded a
retraction and an apology it is yet to
get either alastair sky news in
jerusalem